so welcome to finding go thank you this
is our kind of everything room this is
like mine okay this is for speed over
there I know there's a coffee machine I
think it talks to you we're just
chilling at Fandango I'm Niki Novak and
I'm here with the star of cocoa for
coming and hanging out with thank you so
first of all congratulations thank you
an order you're how old now I'm 13 years
old you're 13 yeah I knew first audition
for Coco when you were how old 9 Wow so
this has been a long time coming
yes and I kind of feel like this like
were you born to play this role do you
feel like you wanted me to go
yes identify myself looking to go a lot
like we both love music and we're both
around the same age and yeah you both
have a dog
yeah how'd it go yeah what's the first
dog I get I'm a common dolphin
what is that like going to Pixar and
working with Disney and it's just like a
wonderful day I get to spend there's
just so much fun
anything to declare as a matter of fact
yes the heart of the film is basically
the importance of family and remembering
your ancestors and I can't wait for all
of you guys to see it
[Music]
[Music]
you